So why is the game of
Jeopardy hard for a computer?
We said earlier that Watson had
3,000 processors and a database
of 200 million pages
of information.
So shouldn't it be easy for
Watson to play Jeopardy?
Unfortunately, Jeopardy
has a wide variety
of categories which are
purposely made cryptic.
While computers can easily
answer precise questions,
like computing the square
root of a complicated number,
understanding natural language
is hard for computers.
As an example, suppose we ask
Watson to answer the question:
Where was Albert Einstein born?
Stored in its
database, Watson might
have the following information:
"One day, from his city
views of Ulm, Otto
chose a watercolor
to send to Albert Einstein as a
remembrance of his birthplace."
As a human, we can
probably figure out
that the name of
the city is Ulm,
but this is a hard
sentence to parse.
How would you tell a computer
that Albert Einstein was
born in Ulm using
just this sentence?
OK.
So how about if we
just store answers
to all possible questions that
could be asked on Jeopardy?
Unfortunately, this
would be impossible.
An analysis of 200,000
previous Jeopardy questions
yielded over 2,500
different categories,
and new questions are created
on Jeopardy all the time.
Well, OK, then let's
just search Google
for the answer to the question.
Unfortunately, no links
to the outside world
are permitted on
Jeopardy, and this rule
applied to Watson as well.
And even if Watson could search
the internet for the answer
to a question, it can
take considerable skill
to find the right web page
with the right information.
So instead, Watson
used analytics
to answer the
Jeopardy questions.
Watson received each
question in text form.
Normally, the players see
and hear the questions,
but Watson couldn't
hear anything,
so they decided to feed him
the questions in text instead.
With the question
in text form, IBM
was able to use text analytics
and other analytical methods
to make Watson a
competitive player.
Overall, they used 100
different techniques
for analyzing natural
language, finding hypotheses
for the questions, and
ranking these hypotheses
to pick an answer.
Watson had a huge database of
sources and several basic tools
to help understand language.
The database consisted of a
massive number of data sources,
like encyclopedias,
texts, manuals, magazines,
and downloaded
pages of Wikipedia.
One of the tools Watson
had was a lexicon,
which describes the relationship
between different words.
For example, the lexicon
could tell Watson
that water is a clear liquid,
but not all clear liquids
are water.
Another tool Watson
had was a part
of speech tagger and parser.
This would identify
functions of words in text.
For example, it would
know that the word "race"
can be used as a verb or a noun.
"The students had to
race to catch the bus"
uses race as a verb, while
"Please indicate your race"
uses race as a noun.
Then, using these data
sources and tools,
Watson would answer
a question by going
through four major steps.
The first step is
question analysis,
where Watson tries
to figure out what
the question is looking for.
The second step is
hypothesis generation,
where Watson searches
the information
sources for possible answers.
After this, Watson
moves on to step
three, when the different
hypotheses are scored.
This means that a
confidence level
has to be computed
for each answer.
The final step is
ranking the hypotheses
to look for a
highly-supported answer.
In the next two videos, we'll go
through how each of these steps
work.